dans le cadre des 170 ans de l'abolition
de l'esclavagé le moment vécu lors de ce
vernissage est particulier car la
culture offre alors une opportunité de
réflexion le devoir de mémoire n'a de
sens que si elles préparent l'avenir et
préparer l'avenir c'est être
d'aujourd'hui être d'aujourd'hui c'est
toujours cette logique de voir comment
se faire rencontrer la mémoire mais
l'histoire la musique la création sens
large du terme
eh bien le moment de voir comment on
peut retrouver des repères commençant à
tomber deux jeunes scaleform de
passéisme l'on peut revendiquer ce qui
était une identité se construit avec son
histoire est sans nul doute le jour de
l'abolition a été un marqueur historique
ainsi la découverte du tableau original
de l'allégorie de l'abolition de
l'esclavagé reste un moment d'émotion
cska mais l'homme qui tend la main vers
ça c'est comme une représentation
symbolique une amende tout c est ça qui
accepte le contrat qu'on continue à
travailler et vous aurez la liberté en
travaillant c'est un tableau qui est
mythique puisque dans tous les ouvrages
consacrés sur la réunion et notamment
quand on parle de la beauce est un
esclavage
c'est tout ça bout et dans tous les hits
dans tous les livres sur l'esclavagé le
tableau illégalement c'est un des trois
tableaux qui a été pas en france
en 1849 pour commémorer l'abolition
esclavage 2148 il revient à la réunion
en plus à la veille de la signature du
décret d'abolition servage quelques pas
plus loin la troisième partie de cette
exposition c'est une autre
interprétation
soixante mille ex clave deviennent
libres après ce discours
et tous ont enfin eu un non j'ai été
surpris de voir mon nom de famille sur
ça fait bizarre je ne savais pas je sais
pas j'ai montré déjà mais en revanche ce
moment où les gens sont en fait obtenu
un non c'est ainsi des moments
charnières dont sandrine et c'est au
niveau de 17 des scolaires
sans aucun doute il essayé de recoller
les bouts de l'histoire comme tout le
monde essaie de le faire à la réunion
une vision contemporaine de cet
événement et pour aller de l'avant
avancez vers la lumière adresse avancé
dans le dans le présent vers le futur
sort dans le fénoir pour s'approprier
son histoire et profiter de cette chance
l'exposition au musée léon dierx est
visible jusqu'au 15 septembre du lundi
au samedi de 9h à 17h30
[Musique]